Destiny...
helps people believe there's an
order to this horseshit.
There isn’t.
You don't believe in destiny...
or the lesser evil.
What do you believe in?
The girl...
in the woods will be with you always.
You saved my life.
I must repay you.
I...
claim the tradition as you have.
The law of surprise.
Destiny can go f...
What have you done Witcher?
You're bound to this now Geralt,
whether you like it or not.
You lecture me on made up cures
for having a child,
meanwhile you cheat
with destiny to steal one.
You can't outrun destiny just
because you're terrified of it,
it’s coming, Geralt.
I can’t sleep.
You will try to outrun the girl
in the woods but you cannot.
Why would I give my only heir
to someone who never cared
enough to come back for her?
Find Geralt of Rivia...
he is your destiny.
If you dismiss it...
you will surely unleash...
true calamity...
upon us all.
Where is Cirilla?
I have to find my destiny.
She is your destiny.
The bond that will come in to being
between you and this child
will be extraordinary.